so let's start here uh this is a very
small
brief question at least in the setup you
were given this
cubic function you're told it had one
real root
and then you were asked to solve for k
all right so the first thing that most
of you thought
uh most of you is you thought okay it's
to do with roots
i'm going to go for and it's also to do
with one of the coefficients
i'm going to go for like sum and product
of roots and all the different
combinations
thereof for a cubic function okay
so you would say oh okay i can do the
sum of the roots
one at a time and i can do them two at a
time
uh let's see oops plus
alpha gamma uh
hold on i feel like i'm missing one
alphabet alpha
no but that's it um and then
three at a time
okay so you went there but you
couldn't get very far you couldn't get
very far because there just wasn't
enough information given to you
to use this there wasn't any like oh
this route and that route
here's some information that will help
you distinguish between them so if you
floundered around trying to do something
here that was
at least valid internally then you
probably got
one or two if you went a very long way
but you simply couldn't get to a value
of k
right um next in a similar vein some
people thought that's cool
i know about real roots i'll just throw
the discriminant at it
cool and most of you said you know the
discriminate
b squared minus 4ac the only problem
with that is that this is the
discriminant
for not cubics but quadratic functions
right cubics have a discriminant
but for a very obvious reason we don't
look at them because there's
more coefficients the discriminant is
not this nice simple thing it's just
awful it takes like half a page to write
the discriminant okay
so and none of you actually did the
description so that wasn't very useful
okay
so how do you approach it how do you
approach it um
the the simplest most the clearest way
most direct way is the calculus okay
so here's the situation that i can
envision i've got two cases
okay this is a cubic right now you have
a look and you
look at the leading coefficient the
leading coefficient
what's the leading coefficient in this
case it's one
the leading coefficient is the
coefficient of the leading term the
leading term is the one with the degree
in it right it's cubed
okay so being that it's one or more
specifically it's positive one okay
you already know roughly what this thing
is going to look like
right all cubics have this kind of
characteristic shape
if you want one real root here's one
example of how it might look
um
there you go that's got one more room
okay um you might notice for instance
that i can't have you know say
um something like this
i can't have something like this despite
the fact that this only intersects with
the
x-axis one time it doesn't have one real
group how many rubrics does that have
this is a cubic right i think it's got
three it's got three they just all
happen to be in the same spot
okay and we looked at this on the
multiplicity of fruits so
that's not an option this works this
works one real group
okay but this is not the only way to
have one real group right
what's another alternative
how could i change this so it would be
because remember
what is this k this k is just an up down
thing
okay it's um it's our vertical constant
okay so as i change this value
i shift up or shift down okay
if i shift up i just have the same kind
of curve right
if i shift down if i shift far down
enough
so that both these stationary points are
below the axis
something like this
then this also has one really good okay
now
these are the only two cases this is
case one
and this is case two there is no other
way
for a cubic to have one real root okay
so now you're looking okay well what
makes it what makes case one case one
and what makes case two case two well
i can see that if this stationary point
here this local minimum right
if it was any lower than here i'm in
trouble right
so i'm looking for this minimum okay if
i can get its y
value to be above the axis to be greater
than zero
uh if i can get y to be greater than
zero
for this value then i'm good okay
in exactly the same way but in reverse
if you get this maximum here
okay and if you get the maximum below
the axis
y is less than zero in the same way
your home and host okay so how do i get
these stationary points let's call this
thing let's call this
um polynomial p okay so differentiate
like p dash
even those of you who didn't do it this
way can tell me right now it's an
easy enough one to compute what is the
derivative of p
you're going to start with 3x squared
right minus
6x minus 24. okay there you go
there's the derivative what am i after
again what am i looking for
i'm looking for stationary points right
so i'm going to let this equal to 0. so
when you solve that
3x squared minus 6x minus 24 equals 0
for stationary points you get we can
divide 3x3
obviously so you get this
okay factoise for me it's a nice easy
one what are our factors
2 and negative 4 to a negative 4. okay
so you're going to get this
so now i know i have stationary points
here right stationary points there but
of course those values themselves the x
values
they're not of that much use to me right
because they tell me
negative two and four they tell me
horizontally where i'm situated but i'm
not interested in horizontal i'm
interested in up down
i want to get this minimum high enough
or this maximum
low enough okay that's negative two
oh my scale died you get the idea okay
so if what i want is actually the y
value i'm gonna need to take these
and pop them back into my original
equation well i named it p
okay so i'm going to say well what's p
of negative two
p omega two which by the way you don't
need any calculus to see that that's
going to be the maximum
right um it's because of the leading
coefficient like i said it's sine
what is p of negative 2
i think you evaluate it i've already
evaluated it you get
don't forget there's a k there you get k
plus 28
okay so you can see based on the value
of k you're going to move
that stationary point up and down okay
so this one what they say negative two
this is the um that's the max
okay right there the other stationary
point is the minimum
and that's at p of four okay and i think
for memory you get k minus 80 when you
slap it in
okay so now what do i want
i want the maximum let's look at this
case this is case two
i want the maximum to be below zero okay
so maybe i should have done it in order
all right
case one i want the minimum to be above
k minus 80 to be above
the axis okay from which you get k is
greater than 80
and then you look at case two the one i
started with
i want this one to be below the axis
because this
is the maximum am i looking at i think
yes okay so k is less than negative 28
there you go these two values so you've
got
k is greater than 80 or k is
less than negative 28.
okay now there was just one other way
that you could think about this
apart from doing this and saying oh i
want them to be
positive negative you can come back to
these two
and you can see something quite clever
um have a look at case one and case two
right i can not only think about the
minimum
being such and such a height i can see
that
in both cases right i've got for
instance this stationary point and this
stationary point i want them both on the
same side of the axis right
so in other words they're both positive
yes if one of them is below and one of
them
i'm in trouble here i've got both
stationary points and they're both below
the axis
right they're both negative okay so
again if i've got one above and one
below i'm in trouble
so here they're both positive right so
whatever the values are like they can be
anything there's a big range
i want um k sorry
yeah k plus 28 k minus 80.
okay when you multiply them two positive
numbers or to be positive
right does that make sense and then here
i want well when i multiply them
together two negatives
two negatives the two negatives should
cancel right
so in fact this case and this case
they both share this in common right
that this is a bit more obscure
but you can see it's kind of an elegant
way to go about it it's like i want both
of these to be on the same side of the
axis
which means if i take their product it
ought to be positive okay
so that's an alternative writing that
mine and green is an alternative to
going through this but you can see it
gives you exactly the same solution
okay it's just a it's just a quadratic
and you get its inequality
okay